on this episode Todd green stops by
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
Gary bean
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 252 of the askgaryvee
show
I'm excited about this we got connected
on the DM on Instagram we are we planned
it and we made it happen we are yeah
want you to tell the vaynernation who
you are and what you do my friend what's
up everybody my name is Kai green aka
mr. getting it done I'm a competitive
athlete that had an opportunity to step
into a larger possibility currently we
are working on a number of projects and
with that an owner of a company dynamic
muscles something acting writing and I
am in awe of being here Gary Vee show
okay why don't you tell everybody a
little bit let's take it further back
right so obviously we've been promoting
that this is going to be on yes we have
questions are we live yeah good
everybody live everywhere are they
putting out phone numbers in the
facebook so Facebook start putting out
your phone numbers to get on the show
and ask a question so we've been phoning
it you've been promoting it people and
really excited about this collaboration
which really is a lot of fun but for a
lot of the audience that may not know
your back story all the way back tell me
about where were you born how'd you get
some humongous how did you get how did
you become a competitive athlete and
like pick me back a little bit further
okay well you know what I started out my
three boy out of people I was 24 one
love it work so I'm a New Yorker
yeah or her you were always here you've
always stayed here I moved around a
little bit but um I grew up dumb in
Brooklyn um I forgot older we came out
from
yep got a chance to live out of state
and currently we spend a lot more time
traveling so abroad so we get a chance
to because of a lot of our businesses
international we spend a lot more time
traveling but yes so they grow up in
Brooklyn and I am in the process of
trying to answer this question if I grew
up in Brooklyn what kind of kid were you
what were you into were you two sports
when you look into video games were you
like quiet
did you read like what was your love
your jam let's call it first to seventh
grade first it sounds great I think
gummy I think we were set up with a lot
of challenges rigging there was a ward
of the state so I guess we're challenged
as it yeah it could be imagined I think
the first to seventh grade I think you
spent the large part of the time just
trying to become a little bit better
adjusted and that was very elusive
barrier and you say we you mean siblings
um yeah you know my brother and I were
rewards of the state so we kind of at
what age somewhere but I would say
around 8:00 8:00 so we kind of let home
pretty young yeah pretty young but
that's the very interesting thing about
the story because there was another time
when you probably probably would have
looked like what would become a negative
statistic and definitely the story
wasn't a very easy one but it is a story
that talks about the path of becoming
and right now I'm very very excited
about the higher heights that we've got
a chance to grow to and are still in the
process of rolling of course well you're
a young dude and so and so what was a
turning point in your in your younger
age like when did you get into body your
competitive bodybuilding I want to go on
he's like terminology here you know what
did you get into exercise and physical
strength early on it was was there a
turning point was there was there when
you say awarded the state
did you have foster parents like what
what's that is I want to make sure yeah
yeah so what happens is you have the
probably thousands of young people right
now that for one reason or another find
themselves in the situation where their
parents aren't able to take care of them
and in a situation like that then the
state steps in and either by force or
you know they step in and they offer
these services and you'll have a bunch
of places either through like the
Catholic Church or various other kinds
of institutions they'll have
institutions but they can be run by any
number of it's very interesting is it
kind of not something that I really do a
lot of thinking about in the present
more in the present now you think about
you know managing the company really
about developing your career everything
about focusing on so this is very
interesting you know it's interesting I
think I think a lot of the future is
told by the past right like listen I'm
not looking to pry like if that's a
chapter that you wanted to close the
book on and you're focusing forward I
want to be empathetic because I don't I
don't have that context but I do think
it's interesting because I think it
builds it speaks to the foundation to me
you know entrepreneurship building brand
some of the businesses you guys are
building through I believe the ones that
grow up with more adversity are far more
positioned for success because you know
I'm sure you've you figured out and I'm
sure your crews figured out like all it
is is adversity like you've got a lot of
awareness and you've built a big
community so obviously there's a lot of
opportunities however business is hard
like you know like it's way harder than
people think it is and and and and
whatever new product or service that you
guys launch truth is nobody gives a [ __ ]
right like just because you work
successful at there when I sort of
social media agency everybody makes fun
of me they're like wine boy stay in your
lane like what do you what are you doing
right so like being successful in one
genre
you know there's you're met with a lot
of cynicism when you go into different
places have you thought about that
Oh in the past what I would do is play
my cards very close to my chest
first thing that
and I still think it's very important
when you have some goals and ideas that
are big sometimes they may be too large
for the current capacity which you're
willing to work you know which means
that you're going to have to do some
growing in an effort to even be able to
stand in that reality but more
importantly when you start to talk about
sharing it with other people sometimes
you might need to keep it close to your
chest because they won't be willing to
accept it and the first thing they'll do
is discourage you yeah it's an
interesting insight you know it's been
funny that's a very interesting insight
I mean I'm going to jump in here for a
second I think it's so funny that
there's two paths so and so often
there's two paths right the two paths
that is such an interesting way of
looking at it I I'm funny I go the other
way I put my [ __ ] out there so
aggressively because I'm I actually need
people to tell me that I can't I'm the
reverse when people you know it's so
funny I had somebody come up to me not
too long ago who was like hey man you
know oh my god you know can I talk sure
we started talking for a second is like
I gotta just tell you I hated you at
first and I was like and he's like and
what really sucked was after a while I
realized me leaving negative comments
and I he's like I gotta be honest like I
left negative comment and then he's like
and then some video I saw and I could
tell that you liked it that I was
leaving negative comments and that
really [ __ ] with me because I was like
now what do I do
and so like it's interesting that like
there's like for me I need to put stuff
out because I feed off of the cynicism
and the people chipping at it and then
and then I have a lot of friends who
keep it close and they're mold is to
like keep it there and then it's just an
interesting psychology well you know um
as a bodybuilder I think one of the
interesting things about the subcultures
I learned to work in silence in any kind
of kind of become a hermit you go into
the underground and you kind of put your
body of work together and then the day
of the competition you unveil it you
know a lot of times people will talk a
very good game I think most people have
not yet really mastered the ability to
to be a Muhammad Ali so to speak you
know talk a good game would still stay
very focused on creating the drive the
design and result that they're looking
for some people get distracted and then
since you distract themselves I'd rather
just because of the way I was socialized
in my subculture to do it that way I put
my hood on and I work I can show you
better than I can tell you I understand
and a lot of times what happens is the
body of work will speak for itself
100% results speak tightly like doesn't
like you know my career when you say
Muhammad Ali a couple us looked at each
other because I think I mean it's an
audacious thing but I love the idea that
I talk a big game
I need it too then there's nothing
better we we we put on a pedestal the
people that talk the biggest game and
are able to actually deliver I mean and
then we don't even know the people that
talk to big game and couldn't deliver we
don't even remember who they were right
so I think I think that's an interesting
insight migrator and let's give us a
question so what else for you so what
are you in specifics what are you most
excited about right now right now I'm
excited about being here
oh you know give it a very very very
focused um you know currently we're
working on a bunch of projects one which
is very very big for us
even in my subculture is the release of
generation ready to it it's the second
film where we get a chance to present
for the subculture everybody in the
spotlight of working towards the
achievement of their goal and not
necessarily just focused around winning
a title or show but actually stepping
out into life and aiming to be
successful that's cool when's that come
out what comes out in May we're actually
going to body power this weekend next
week actually to set up the premiere in
UK love it got it
Dylan Dylan scary beer on the askgaryvee
show with hi how are you oh [ __ ]
how's it going Dylan watching the world
trailer five years ago and now you're on
the show oh okay possible shout-out to
you guys too you will not be able to
survive you could go oh so what you
question my friend and so I want to ask
you about confident the gospel [ __ ]
like your daily routine that works on
long as you know well we have a digital
marketing agency but it was like the
whole class making out and stuff like
what she won't say that's the dice on
national polls well how do you think
about your time management your daily
routine well I think one thing you like
what I think about doing is aiming to be
early I think if you're very effective
they need to be early you're least
likely to be late
that is absolutely true absolutely but
then also being clear about what your
priorities are because there any time we
said except set ourselves up for
schedule um you may find that other
things may come up and they'll always
are going to be things that will pull at
your concentration and I think the more
successful you become with managing
yourself you become more attractive
which means that more things will pull
at your concentration I think you've got
to make your actions back up your
ambition right like my process is very
simple which is I've taught the big game
I have a lot of wants and dreams and my
schedule today needs to map my big
[ __ ] mouth
right like that's it and so you know one
thing that shocks people when they get
close to remember and Tyler first filmed
for Justin first film iris when you
forget to film the biggest thing you're
going to know is like wait a minute
it's every second it's actually every
second like it's you know like I think
time is the asset and so the one thing I
would tell you is as you're prospecting
as you're trying to get sales you've
also got to deliver on your work if
you've got an agency like selling just
the beginning Sally Sally said like
you're like everybody so far
I'm selling a lot of people starting
these small social media agencies just
to get clients they forget that after
you get the clients you got a [ __ ]
deliver keeping business the keeping
business is what actually builds big
businesses not getting you business so I
would I would I would I would add to the
process to make sure you're talking to
your current customers not just trying
to find new ones well cool man thank you
all right let's get so much good fine
you like that I think I think farming so
hunting is very attractive right like
it's no different kind of them it's a
it's a little version of what you said
which is let the action speak instead of
the words it's how I think about
business I'm a big talker but from a
business standpoint people see me in my
sales and all this but it's the farming
it's it's the retaining clients it's the
meetings it's the maintenance of Mainers
100% see if Scott comes through its
caller from Jacksonville Florida is the
Geary show it sure is Scott neuron with
Cod me and how are you I'm scary
gentlemen it is an honor Gary I'll tell
you something to crush it changed my
life I appreciate it and the one thing I
love about you Gary is you engage with
your followers and I thank you for that
number one person okay thank you and
then the more core sample of highest
when you wake up in the morning and you
don't feel like going to the gym how do
you have to go down and say I've got it
do this
I think I think it varies I think
there's some illusion I mean it yes yes
multiple hats yes yes we do yeah but I
mean also my my ambition was to be the
best in my craft the best in my field
the best and is that mr. Olympia like is
that liquid that is considered well
you'd wash it's not as much anymore now
I like watching your team we after this
show because I don't have I don't have
the subtext I'm going to say I like
what's happening because I'm getting
excited I'm like I got a Google some
[ __ ] after the dinner promotion yeah
that we're definitely not trying to
indirectly do to say that there was a
time when you know to be the best
athlete in the world meant that we had
to get up and follow a certain protocol
is is the most important way that I
would like to answer that question and
even even now whether it is the mr.
universe whether it's you know whatever
said championship or not reality is that
in order to be the best you know you
have to be willing to give a certain
amount of your concentration in your
time on dutifully every day to make that
a reality
do you struggle to go to the gym Scott
Scott yes doing yes I do actually guys
because you know I'm 55 years old I you
know I want to look good I want to stay
healthy and Gary you inspired me to do
that because I see you out there all the
time and you are moving and I think when
people just sit around all day they
become sedentary then you lose the
battle so yeah I go to Planet Fitness
here in Jacksonville three times a week
to stay fit not only for me in my life
but for my upcoming grandchildren I love
that man I think that's great my answer
is that Jordan just keeps texting me
until I get out of bed that's my move
Scott thanks for watching the show I
will say this I wouldn't throw this at
you Scott or anyone else that's
listening is is a lot of that is really
about remembering what is important
being able to be in touch with your why
a lot of people have heard that stuff
but you know I think whether you're
professional athlete or your rich person
are saying hey I want to be in good
health I want to be in good shape this
is what I need to do I think you're more
likely to lose focus or more likely to
want to stay in the bed and not go when
you are not looking at the end result
that you're looking for you know I you
know when did you start working out for
real
I thought attorney was like not
really yeah use this I started fishing
for this before 21st birthday 90 you
ever work out nine days this guy's
terrible Melanie I don't care get it
through this hey it's Gary B and you're
the askgaryvee show with Ty Greene who's
this and where you from oh man this is
super crazy uh my name is Kenya I really
didn't think this is gonna was gonna
happen at all well you got you okay okay
you put your phone number in the screen
I mean you could you had a think it had
a chance of happening uh yeah 300 but
where are you from I'm an I'm from San
Antonio love it
welcome here for you know uh my question
the limit I put in there yes I'm running
an advertising agency called a project
forward
okay and I was wondering how do you find
out how big of a client you should go
for I just started I have three meetings
this week
nice uh I started like a year ago but I
just got to the part where I'm hearing
so nice so yeah so I have like three
minutes this week even if I closed all
of them I'll still like they're very
small so I'm wondering how do you find
out how big of client you should go for
and well the answer is you should go for
the biggest clients you can possibly get
right like I mean you should go for you
know Apple and and BMW what I think
you're self-aware enough to know is that
they're not going to hire you so I think
I think what you need to do is stretch
your ambitions and stay practical at the
same time so I think what I just heard
is I would have loved for you to have
five meetings or three or or two
meetings of the way the three look and
then one is a stretch goal right like I
think you should always ask you know
sliding into DMS writing writing emails
putting out content that's a gateway to
the agency I think it's super important
that you like what I did with
vaynermedia to give you an example is we
started off and it was like $3,000 a
month and then people said yes and the
next meeting no matter what it was
$4,000 a month I just kept going until I
became $15,000 a month
yes some said no but I remember when I
was at eleven thousand a month there was
like seven or eight meetings in a row
that were knows and I was like I didn't
feel like I should have went backwards I
still felt confident I felt like eleven
wasn't enough maybe 150 but not eleven
and I hear people emailing me like Gary
oh I'm really struggling I don't think
it's working I think I have a bad idea
and I reply like I did some sales
meeting so they didn't go well I'm like
how many of you done there like two and
I'm like let me get this straight
we've done two sales calls sales
meetings and they didn't go well and
you're questioning your entire [ __ ]
right I mean like you know how many you
know some days don't go good in gym
right like you didn't go as well as you
wanted to it didn't click you know but
so I would say it's not about knowing
how big you should go for its that you
should try to go for as big as you can
then you service it and if you can see
that they're satisfied with it now you
have proof of concept that there's
somebody in the world that's willing to
pay you $6,000 a month and they're happy
about it which then means you have the
potential have a lot more people that
are willing to do that understand
awesome yeah so how did you figure out
that first number though that first
three thousand I made it up okay I was
like hon three thousand sounds right I
[ __ ] made it up great you know how'd
you come up with your first number um
the first person offered it to me and I
was like oh that's way more than I was
expecting you go my man that's how so
many businesses have started the way I
started speaking how much did I want I
made it up and then it was too little
and I made up more and it was still too
little like you know you just you just
go through it it's called stick with me
here experience experience matters all
these youngsters that are super tip
dunked he's so talented and young he
[ __ ] sleeps on experience wait till
he actually has experience then he's
gonna be a real ninja like experience
matters it's how you learned you go
through the battles you're like oh [ __ ]
that's how it happens oh I didn't know
experience is real I thought I was
unstoppable at 23 and I was I felt like
huge business but guess what 41 year old
Gary will destroy 23 year old Gary what
in within one round it's just experience
it's real
got it right yeah pull up your content
by the way and thank you I don't
actually know who's on the show today
pliers so car green checkable follow-up
have big [ __ ] models all right now
play one thing I noticed as we've been
prepping for this through social is kids
freak out when they see you like Islands
like you know like I was really enjoying
like seeing like that must feel amazing
oh no well you know what if it's one of
those things where I don't think that I
spent a lot of time focusing on how I
feel and because much like the the coal
that we had a latterly er how do you how
do you respond when you don't feel like
and most often than not my feelings are
filled will betray me mentally so like I
try not to rely on my feelings and you
know just try to be more consciously
aware of the things that I want my
thoughts and allow my thoughts to lead
me recognize that I need to be able to
control my thinking
so when I feel things that are telling
me eight you know that usually isn't
indicated that I'm not focused where I
need to be in order to make this thing
easier I'm going to jump on that in a
minute
it's Gary Vee you're on the askgaryvee
show who's this and where you from hey
this is Brian Cronin right I love
natural doing good man how about you
good say a lot of kind car what's up man
how you doing sir I'm doing good I just
watched a documentary on you got to go
and go on that book Thank You mr.
Olympia very impressive how do you feel
about that guy jeomsun all right what's
your question my name is Rivage that's
why the lines got run instead of a
social media for his business he has a
few gym here in the natural area he's a
bodybuilder he's one of us your tendency
I believe ones your clients and now he's
come to me and is asking you know Brian
how do I take my accomplishment and my
personal brand and take it to the next
level so I can monetize that how do I
grow that guy you know so my social
larger start you know looking for
sponsors showing supplement so on and so
forth what is he one of what does he
want to push that
towards is the accomplishment just
financial which is super fun I don't
want yeah well I mean every I mean here
yeah I mean I think I think he's got to
pick the things that he wants a dancer
is you need to bring value to people so
they follow you and then you decide what
you want to move your audience to and
you need to believe in what you sell
right like just get it right
I remember I was visceral against
supplements over the last decade because
the first eighty people I met I knew
didn't give a [ __ ] about what was in the
supplements they were just slapping some
label on some [ __ ] they bought in China
and so I was like and I remember
thinking [ __ ] this is scary these are
like friends or claims that I like bro
what it's like it for years it's found
out that you don't even know what you're
buying what if people died from cancer
like how could you live like this so I
like just was like completely right you
know now to become a little more
educated started getting my fenders
better I started meeting people that are
actually from the fitness game and care
about it and like do the home run Jordan
is so unbelievably knowledgeable like
the way he talks about size thoughtful
it's thoughtful it stops flapping a
private label on the cheapest pills in
bulk they could buy in Alibaba and
trying to flip them on your or Twitter
account so I think the answer is very
simple my man he needs to bring value to
people and you can only do so much
because he has to bring value it's not
that you can manipulate that and then he
needs to decide what he wants to push
that audience to and he needs to feel
good about it so if he feels good that
his Jim's work $2.99 a month like the
reason it's so easy for me to sell books
is I just think it's really worth 14
[ __ ] dollars like you know like you
got to feel good about what you sell so
I would tell you you need to get serious
with him and not have a surface level
conversation with him you need to stress
test the relationship and put him in a
position that he has to understand maybe
I said first bring value to people on
social and then need to push them
towards something he really believes in
and that takes time not hey Brian get my
social up so we make some money yeah if
you think everybody can see the answer
towards this is there a social media
platform that you would wanted to focus
more depands attention on or that well
how much it does Annette well to echo
what you said about taking the
developing giving something in use value
that you can believe in um you can I
guess you know Facebook would be really
cool but you can go on and develop your
YouTube channel and give some really
good practical advice that starts to
talk about helping people overcome or
deal with some of the issues that
they're wrestling with maybe you can
think about speaking to a unique market
there are a lot of people that are
dealing with a host of issues that diet
or different dieting strategies can help
not just talking about the mr. mrs.
Jones that wants to lose a few dress
sizes but the person that's actually
needs to eat in a specific way to combat
some of the health crisis that they find
and as a result aren't as easy or find
it not as easy to find those answers you
know just you know out there I think you
could you could develop a resource that
speaks to that specific group or or a
bunch of different needs and now create
something of a substantial use value
that is worth the subscription price on
your own you know or actually
technically more than that you know so
you give more in use value than the
actual dollar figure that you charge
from truck tried-and-true advice man
provide people value up front then sell
them something you believe in super
simple cool yep I by the way to answer
your question Instagram Facebook YouTube
snapchat and Twitter on the next tier
below that but the three things above
that priority you can't can't win in
2017 without a substantial Instagram
Facebook and YouTube strategy can't win
your honor and that's on video and so
then if you want to about ran medium
LinkedIn your own blog and then if you
want to talk about audio your pop your
own podcast other people's podcasts
Spotify believe it or not SoundCloud
Believe It or Not content on music
platform
I think is a arbitrage got it cool off
the ramp that's pretty erotic that YESCO
jess is right hi
I really appreciate you man Oh likewise
yeah thanks for being a show what's the
question of the day you get to ask the
whole vaynernation any question you want
good opportunity for you and your team
to get to 3,000 answers across Facebook
and YouTube of maybe some insight some
friends something you're curious about
what the masses are thinking question is
it could be something funny like what's
your favorite root beer like question of
the day go uh well um hmm Wilk I answer
this question directly or not that's a
joke ah I saw some of that come through
a social um I really don't question
today are you ever curious with money in
your world what do you what are some of
the themes that people are talking about
or thinking about um in my world nope
I'm thinking about improving my game in
my world I'm thinking about I mean
everybody wants will ask questions that
are my new [ __ ] well how many grams
protein right right the commodity [ __ ]
but that's you know the stuff that
doesn't matter
recognizing that I am I am in control
you know
I decide what's going to happen or not
you know I can plan the fact that we are
ineffectively I can stand in my own way
or become my own more most powerful ally
so I guess maybe the question today is
who are you what are you willing to be I
love that I appreciate it thank you you
keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]